if 10 men come up to you at a bar
restaurant Library wherever you meet men
what percentage of men are dateable
Sarah you can go first what percentage
of men
are dateable out of the tenants step two
at a bar hey what's up you're looking
good can I get you a drink I don't
really know if they're dable because I
don't really know anything about them
you know a girl knows in the first five
seconds
one percent yeah okay so not even one so
you chop that one guy up into 10 pieces
let's make a five okay five percent yeah
so not even one guy that steps to you
guys hardly yeah Ali I know that you're
married so Tom forgive us for a second
ten dudes step two at a bar how many of
those guys are datable I mean honestly
maybe one physically for sure one but
then the the hot boys sometimes they're
not ready to settle down so that could
drop it easily to like a 0.5 but it's
Slim Pickens out there I observe by
people watch all the time and that's why
how I can tell there is a problem with
masculinity and in that same vein though
there's definitely a problem with
femininity like how many women out there
are truly dateable like I don't know
dateable and bangable are two different
questions okay
um but we'll get we'll keep it moving
Leia you're in my me now people are
stepping to you all the time what
percentage of men are datable I think it
depends what kind of woman you are
really I think like I was complaining
earlier about this to a friend I think
like if you would regard yourself
everything is like personal perspective
if you as a woman regard yourself as
like an average woman then you're going
to be happy with like the average man
um and so I would probably say like I
don't know let's say there's a group of
10 men five a dateable right because you
perceive yourself as the average woman
um but if you perceive yourself to be
you know more than the average woman and
you know we all know the term hypergamy
women date upwards
um then yes I mean you're lucky if even
one of those ten men are gonna be
marryable so the lesson here is that
because you know familiar with the
Pareto Principle but the 80 20 rule
basically the top 20 of men get 80 of
women technically 100 want the top 20 of
men yeah but lesson here to you
gentlemen out there you gotta improve
okay whether that's physically your game
money because if you step to a woman a
bar based on what we've learned here
from these wonderful women there's a 90
chance she's gonna be like P
for my standard yes
um
maybe like one okay so just you're
reaffirming everything so friendly but
like would I maybe pursue you probably
like one two if we're in a certain
setting okay maybe what do you mean
certain setting
um it depends if you're like at a club
versus maybe like a high-end restaurant
at the bar
you're at the store or it really depends
where you are like if you're at the gym
if you're shopping at Saks Fifth Avenue
all ten guys
I spent a million hours on this the one
thing that each of these guys can
approve so basically if 10 guy stepped
you you only pick one if you could give
advice to the other nine what's sort of
the uniform advice of like dress better
you know have better game like brush
your teeth like please you know [ __ ]
whatever it is what's like the one thing
that can improve the odds for most men
quick answer go ahead Leo I think the
easiest thing a mind can do is just look
better right like hit the gym look
strong women like safety so if you come
up to her and you look big and strong
done you know that that gets you over
the first hurdle the rest of course
there are other hurdles but that gets
you in the door to some extent okay do
you agree with that Ally what's the one
thing you would change for most men no I
definitely agree I mean 73.6 of the
American population is overweight to
include obesity and those are Americans
like 21 years old and older so that's
that's men and it's women so a lot of
these dudes are talking about women
aren't looking at me I mean to be blunt
my Olympic system is not attracted to
your Pudge so like first and foremost do
something about that and then it's even
cooler too because you can be fit I'm
very strict teaching about dating though
so you can be a fit buff guy but you
know what's cooler too though is if
you're good at Combat Sports because I
know you can just take out my enemies
both foreign and domestic and if you
can't I mean I get it it's tough to get
into Combat Sports but it's just so hot
but um if you can't you can learn how to
handle a firearm like let me let me feel
safe I worry about my physical safety
not at all with my husband oh okay Sarah
what's the one thing you would give
advice for guys to improve upon
coming up to you to buy
Carol you said not even one out of ten
what would help you like in general
anywhere in life ah
I don't know I don't know I don't know
dress better not be so pushy be
confident
you do know because you just said four
answers okay so dress better don't be
pushy what else
yeah she knows see not that hard you got
this thing not what about you
um I mean obviously your first
impression is what you look like so
keeping yourself together like you look
clean you look together
um and then from there conversation like
a good one-liner opening like nobody
likes a weird good looking guy
is like he's hot and then he opens his
mouth you're like holy crap like please
go with that surgery it happens a lot
more than people would think it's true
like game does matter game totally it
does it does so I mean looks that's kind
of obvious because that's everybody's
first judgment yeah and then um having
like a good open liner yeah
I'll tell you a funny story I have a
good buddy of mine I'm not going to call
him out there good looking dude
played in the NBA
famous tall I know good looking again
I'm not going to say his name and he
would open his mouth and the girl would
be like no and I would consistently say
anytime we got to the bar club
restaurant whatever Library I'd be like
dude stand there look good let me do the
[ __ ] talking okay boom and things
would work out well for us so like
anyway just unless you're a six foot
nine NBA player you're gonna have to
have a [ __ ] mouthpiece right so
you're gonna submit some game all right
thank you for that ladies I think the
gentleman uh hopefully took something
from that hit the [ __ ] gym you don't
have to be a UFC player you don't gotta
you know UFC fighter you don't have to
be uh Conor McGregor to data check but
you know maybe just look decent yeah
protect women so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire saucecast
click right here
thank you